[Music]
in verse opt with passport brings a lot
of value to bluemix we have a very
comprehensive set of user API s that
provide authentication user emailing all
the features that your business needs
when you have users that allow you to
really just bootstrap your app quickly
you pull in all the api's for the rest
of the function that you need and you're
off to the races
passport brings a lot of value to
bluemix we find that that is it your
core business and that isn't what makes
you money so we want to help you get
your product and your application in
bluemix to market quicker member soft
passport really grew out of many years
of observing the same problem with our
customers all of our customers have
users all of our customers have apps and
all of our customers were spending too
much time and resources developing
functionality manage those users but it
wasn't really growing their core
business it wasn't revenue generating
functionality and it wasn't really what
was allowing their businesses to grow so
when you use inverse off passport on
bluemix we're really allowing you to
skip all of that get your products
market faster and focus on the features
that grow your business and give your
customers a better experience if you're
interested if you have users and you
have applications and you're wondering
what to do next a great way to start is
go to the bluemix catalog search on
passport you'll find our referral tile
we've got a full set of step-by-step
documentation on our website as well as
through bluemix we have an example
application that we've written which is
published in open source on github which
should give you a great example to get
started with how to call the API and how
we can bring value to your application
today
[Music]